okay I got here I cannot tell you what I
have been through this evening getting
ready for the star-studded event I had
my hair tortured by Emilio I had my body
pummeled by Hiroshi I had my nails filed
by Philippe
I've been worked over by more aliens
than Sigourney Weaver you made it now I
know you're all on the edge of your
seats dying to know who I'm going to
trash this evening I hate to tell you
this folks there is no trashing to be
done in this category these nominees are
absolutely unbe Smerch of all
nevertheless I'm here anyway because you
may have heard I love this category
scoring yes there is a cheap and vulgar
joke to be made right there and if I
were half as cheap as I look in this
dress
I would tell it but I hardly think that
appropriate for an occasion as pompous
as this one
so we'll save the cheap shots for the
People's Choice Awards film scoring is a
special film scoring enhances the action
and the psychology of movies film scores
are often enduring like da da da da da
da da da
they're often compelling like da da da
da da and they're often emotional like
carrying on in this great tradition
tonight we have five gentlemen and the
nominees for the best original score'
are I think I'll stand up straight for
this one for aliens James Horner
for Hoosiers jerry goldsmith
for the mission Ennio Morricone
a neo has a fan for round midnight
mr. Herbie Hancock
for Star Trek IV the voyage home
and the winner is
I even get to hold this they asked me to
have a speech prepared and this is the
first time I've actually prepared a
speech I never did this before maybe I
have to prepare speeches in the future
in accepting this award I salute the
same unsung heroes that you so boldly
have chosen to apply some are with us
today and some are not
many have suffered and even died for
this music this greatest of all
expression of the creative spirit of
humankind jazz from their suffering and
pain we can learn that life is the
subject the story that that music so
eloquently speaks out and it is not the
other way around we as individuals must
develop our lives to the fullest to
strengthen and deepen the story that
others can be inspired by life's song I
think Gretchen Anthony or when Winkler
frontsies pulled off Dexter Gordon Bruce
Lundvall
William Fletcher Lane and the cast and
crew for the sincere efforts through
love and respect for this american-born
art form called jazz praise has long
been overdue for Bud Powell Lester Young
Thelonious Monk Charlie Parker Billie
Holiday and many many others along with
you I thank them along with them I thank
you